huh all right it's time for CBS mornings
deals where we show you some items that
might help you save some time and some
money all that exclusive low prices and
they just might become Essentials in
your everyday life to start shopping now
scan that QR code on your screen you can
also go to cbsdeals.com right now we
have the other girl in the Bill yes
lifestyle host Gail bass she joins us so
um Gail we all hate that feeling when
you realize oh man I just yes I know the
other girl watch out
I can't find my key yeah I go through
that all the time and research shows
that Americans spend 10 hours a year
looking for those what that research is
based on me alone okay so not scientific
it's like always looking for the keys
looking for everything but I love the
key smart Pro I actually have one it is
a great device because you can store up
to 14 keys on this okay it's Bluetooth
enabled so you can it has the Tile app
so if you lose your key fees you can use
your phone app to track them down or if
you lose your phone it could call your
phone even if it's on silent your phone
will ring so this is a great device
silent even if it doesn't seem like the
airplanes would let you on with this
they will let you on with that because
all that is is just like it's a little
bottle opener so they'll let you on with
this uh yeah open a bottle with it on a
plane fly with it hey I carried mine on
the plane they didn't stop me okay
we are talking 29.99 this is this is uh
this is great on all these products
because they're all 30 or less they
don't carry yeah it'll carry how many
did you say 48 Keys up to 14. 14 keys I
don't want somebody carrying 14. yeah
this is like if you've got a lot ones in
your pocket you're sneaking up on the
kids to see if they clean the room they
won't hear you coming that's the great
thing that's a great thing now this is
something that allows you to charge a
lot of devices all at once I like that
this is the power pro and it is a five
device charger and what's great about it
is it has two outlets it has two USB
ports and a USBC port a lot of stuff is
moving to transitioning to the USBC
what's great about this is that you plug
it into the wall but it could charge
your laptop a couple of phones even your
speaker all at the same time and it's
pretty powerful and it also has surge
protection what's great is at the
holidays you're going to Grandma's house
there's not enough plugs Right girls
weekend same hotel room not enough plugs
like Grandma's table everybody could fit
around I was thinking in the hotel I was
in one recently and had to put stuff in
the bathroom and then stuff by the bed
because stuff is plugged into the hotel
things this is good how much it is great
this is 58 off we have it for
24.99 a great gift a great you know
something really great for the person
who has everything they probably don't
have this or if you know somebody who
has an Airbnb give them that because
that helps put makes it convenient for
anybody coming to your house as a guest
you mentioned Tunes we got Tunes here I
love this uh let me just play this for
you check this out
oh oh my favorite song
this is oh where oh keep it going to get
it out here we go you want to hear some
more yeah all right here we go go ahead
good go ahead and tell us what it is
these are paired this is great you could
have as a single but you can also pair
them this is the raycon everyday speaker
what's great is this was created by
somebody who knows music Ray J Brandy's
brother that family knows music and Ray
J created this yes that's his company
raycon and what's great is that not only
can you pair them these are magazines
little and cute yeah they are very
lightweight you can travel with them you
could take them to the park you could
take it take it to the beach these are
24 nights
stick them on the fridge I was listening
to Travis Travis Tritt making some
making some biscuits in the kitchen look
at Ray J
appreciate it and of course we partnered
with all these companies to get these
incredible deals to buy anything you saw
and the QR code on your screen right now
or head over to cbsdeals.com to start
shopping now for all these items and
more we'll be right back